Si os preguntásemos por Suecia, seguro,
seguro, que automáticamente muchos
pensaríais en el medio ambiente, la lucha contra
el calentamiento global o, incluso, el animalismo.
Al fin y al cabo hablamos de un país en el
que más del 10 por ciento de la población es
vegana o vegetariana y, sí, por supuesto,
¡también es el país de Greta Thunberg!
Así que es posible que muchos penseis
que Suecia es algo así como el feudo
de la lucha contra la contaminación,
la industria y la explotación de los
recursos naturales y el rechazo a la vida
capitalista. El país de las campañas por
un mundo distinto y mejor que deje atrás el
materialismo y los excesos de la humanidad.
Para otros, en cambio, Suecia seguramente sea el
país promotor de la socialdemocracia más radical,
las campañas contra el desarrollo
y básicamente, el rechazo a la vida
capitalista. Otros quizás pensaréis también
en la inmigración o en olas de violencia.
Sea como sea, Suecia suele ser un
país que casi nunca deja indiferente
a nadie. Al menos a casi nadie.
Pero, más allá de la política,
este país también tiene otras facetas muy
diferentes. Por ejemplo, ¿Qué pensaríais
si os dijera que Suecia es asimismo una de
las grandes potencias mineras de Europa?
Sí, sí, potencia minera. Y
aunque eso no sea, precisamente,
lo más eco-friendly del mundo, es
tal cual como lo estáis escuchando.
Claro que dicho esto la pregunta es: ¿Por
qué demonios os ha dado en VisualPolitik
por hablar de la minería en Suecia?
¿Realmente es algo tan relevante?
Pues… sí, lo cierto es que sí.
Tiene mucha más importancia de
lo que podríamos pensar a simple vista. Fijaos.
(12 enero 2022: Suecia encuentra el depósito
más grande de Europa de tierras raras,
que podría volverse “más importante
que el petróleo y el gas” - CNBC)
Tal cual como lo estáis oyendo. Hablamos
de un enorme depósito de alrededor de un
millón de toneladas de óxidos de tierras raras,
que se suma a otros descubiertos en
Finlandia, Grecia y sí, también en España.
(Se conoce como tierras raras a 17 elementos
minerales con propiedades magnéticas,
luminiscentes y electroquímicas únicas.
Entre ellos se encuentran
el lantano o el neodimio,
que se usan entre otras cosas
para fabricar coches, o el itrio,
indispensable para producir cosas tan dispares
como los semiconductores o algunos fármacos.)
Y puede que alguno se esté
preguntando… pero entonces,
¿por qué hablar concretamente de Suecia si hay
depósitos de estos mismos minerales en más países?
Pues no solo porque ese depósito de tierras raras
recién descubierto sea el más grande de Europa,
sino también por otros motivos no
solo relacionados con la minería.
Así que sin hacer más spoiler…
¿Estáis preparados? Pues arranquemos.
(EL RENACER DEL MÚSCULO MINERO)
La minería en Suecia no es precisamente
una actividad nueva. Hablamos de un
sector con mucha tradición que se ha
desarrollado desde hace unos 6.000 años.
De hecho una de sus minas más famosas, la mina
de Falun que ya no está en funcionamiento,
proporcionó enormes cantidades
de cobre durante casi mil años.
Ni más ni menos que desde el siglo X
hasta 1992. De hecho, durante muchos
siglos Suecia tuvo prácticamente el
monopolio del cobre a nivel global.
Así que hablar de Suecia y de la minería no
resulta nada sorprendente. Los lazos entre este
país y este sector han sido históricamente muy
estrechos. Gracias a ello, de hecho, las empresas
suecas han desarrollado algunas de las tecnologías
extractivas más avanzadas y limpias que existen.
Por ejemplo, el hierro en Suecia apenas
genera entre una tercera y una cuarta
parte del impacto ambiental que tiene
en otros países menos desarrollados.
(El caso es que actualmente Suecia tiene
12 importantes minas en funcionamiento,
especialmente en la mitad norte del
país. Todas ellas están dedicadas a la
explotación de metales. Hablamos sobre todo
de hierro, plomo, zinc, oro, plata y cobre.
De hecho, Suecia ha sido el principal proveedor
de hierro en Europa desde el siglo XVIII y
actualmente produce -atentos- más del 90 por
ciento de todo el hierro que se produce en la
Unión Europea, un tercio del plomo y del zinc, y
una décima parte del oro, la plata y el cobre.)
Y, ojo, porque aunque esto puede chocar con
la idea preconcebida que mucha gente tiene de
Suecia - y también con el hecho de que este sector
sea en la actualidad una de los más señalados por
los grupos ecologistas así como esa parte de
la izquierda que he cambiado la revolución del
proletariado por el cambio climático - en este
país se toman tan en serio la minería que incluso
van a cambiar de sitio una ciudad entera para que
una de sus grandes minas pueda continuar operando.
(Una ciudad minera sueca que se hunde en el suelo
será reubicada edificio por edificio - Euronews)
Hablamos, precisamente, de Kiruna, el
mismo lugar donde se ha descubierto el
gran depósito de tierras raras que
mencionamos al comienzo del vídeo.
Pero, al margen de esta anécdota, lo cierto
es que con el cambio de modelo productivo,
la transición energética y la nueva movilidad
impulsada por los gobiernos de todo el mundo,
la minería sueca podría estar a las puertas
de volver a experimentar una época dorada.
Y, ojo, que ni siquiera hablamos solo de
las tierras raras que os hemos mencionado.
En los últimos años también se están
descubriendo grandes depósitos de otros
muchos recursos que resultan absolutamente
estratégicos para el futuro, especialmente
si se quiere cumplir con el objetivo
de cero emisiones de carbono en 2050.
¿Queréis un ejemplo? Pues… Fijaos.
(25 de enero de 2022: United Lithium
descubre dos nuevas pegmatitas ricas en
litio en el proyecto Bergby, en Suecia,
con perforación en curso - The Assay)
Entre el depósito de tierras
raras descubierto en Kiruna y
este de litio Bergby, Suecia podría
convertirse con mucha diferencia en
uno de los países estratégicamente
más importantes de toda Europa.
Para los que no estéis muy puestos en el
tema, estas materias primas, las tierras
raras y el litio, resultan imprescindibles
para fabricar cosas como los coches eléctricos,
los aerogeneradores o gran parte de los
dispositivos electrónicos. Tanto es así que
muchos expertos los consideran más importantes
a largo plazo que el gas o el petróleo.
(“Producir un aerogenerador de 3
megavatios requiere 335 toneladas
de acero, 4,7 toneladas de cobre, 1.200
toneladas de hormigón, 3 toneladas de
aluminio, 2 toneladas de elementos de tierras
raras, así como zinc, lo que es realmente
ilustrativo del volumen de materias primas
que necesitamos para la transición ecológica.
Maroš Šefčovič, Vicepresidente de Relaciones
Interinstitucionales de la Comisión Europea)
Como veis, ahora sabemos que Suecia es un
país muy rico en prácticamente todos estos
recursos. Es el principal productor europeo
de hierro, que es la principal materia prima
que se utiliza para producir el acero, un
importante productor de cobre y zinc y,
ahora, podría convertirse también en un
gran productor de tierras raras y litio.
O con otras palabras, el subsuelo
sueco posee casi todas las materias
primas indispensables para el desarrollo
tecnológico y la transición energética.
Pero ni siquiera se trata sólo de una cuestión
económica… Sino también de seguridad. No es que
Suecia pueda ser un productor más… Sino que
según datos de la propia Comisión Europea,
actualmente en torno al 98% de las tierras
raras que la Unión Europa consume proceden
de un único país, ¿sabéis cuál? 3,2,1…
¡Exacto! La República Popular China.
Os hemos hablado de ello en un pasado vídeo
aquí en VisualPolitik. Y claro, si algo ha
quedado claro en los últimos tiempos es que
depender demasiado de un país para el suministro
de un recurso clave puede tener consecuencias
nefastas. Más aún si ese país es una dictadura
y un régimen cada vez más hostil con occidente
... Como ocurre con Xi Jinping y compañía.
Así que poca broma. Suecia puede suponer
una vía de escape segura para acabar con
esa enorme dependencia y evitar que al
viejo continente le pasen cosas como esta:
(22 septiembre 2010: En medio de las tensiones,
China bloquea exportaciones vitales a Japón
Los funcionarios de aduanas
chinos están deteniendo los
envíos a Japón de las llamadas tierras raras,
evitando que se carguen a bordo de los barcos
en los puertos chinos. - The New York Times)
(29 mayo 2019: China está lista para usar
las tierras raras para contraatacar en la
guerra comercial con Estados Unidos, avisaron
periódicos chinos el miércoles. - Reuters)
Como para confiar en los suministros de China
por mucho que este país tenga aproximadamente
la mitad de todas las reservas probadas
en el mundo de tierras raras. Ojo con eso.
Y, claro, el problema es que según las
estimaciones de la propia Unión Europea,
para el año 2030 la demanda de tierras raras
se va a multiplicar por cinco a nivel mundial:
coches eléctricos, smartphones,
tablets, redes tecnológicas,
aerogeneradores ... .La demanda va a ser brutal.
Y hablamos de menos de siete años. Así que si
no queremos que Xi Jinping tenga la sartén por
el mango hacen falta alternativas… Y justo ahí
es dónde entra en juego Suecia. Y también
otros países como Finlandia, claro está.
Desde luego los burócratas de Bruselas parece que
se están empezando a preocupar por esta cuestión:
(La UE presentará objetivos para la
autosuficiencia de materias primas
En su Ley de Materias Primas Críticas, la
Comisión "mirará más allá de las tierras
raras clásicas, del tipo del escandio" para
centrarse también en otros metales que se
necesitan para la transición ecológica,
dijo Handley. “Y claramente, el cobre
será necesario para la electrificación
de la economía global”. - Euractiv)
Claro que no penséis que esto genera
mucha tranquilidad en el sector. Le
tienen pavor al apetito por la
regulación de Bruselas. Fijaos.
(“En este momento, ¿es una prioridad aumentar
la regulación? No, creo que la prioridad es
tener proyectos exitosos, entregando lo que
necesitas con urgencia”. - Mark Rachovides,
presidente del grupo de presión Euromines, sobre
la futura Ley de Materias Primas Críticas.)
Sea como sea, todo apunta a que Suecia vivirá un
renacer minero en los próximos años. Y que eso
puede ser una gran noticia para toda Europa.
Claro que para que eso sea posible
tenemos que cerrar el triángulo.
Hasta ahora tenemos dos lados:
los recursos disponibles y las
empresas mineras deseando extraerlos.
Pero nos falta el tercero: Estocolmo.
Durante los últimos años el gobierno
socialdemócrata no fue particularmente
amigable con esta industria.
Los procesos burocráticos se
alargaron y las licencias de exploración
y explotación sufrieron enormes retrasos.
De hecho, según la clasificación internacional
del Fraser Institute de Canadá, entre los años
2016 y 2021, Suecia ha pasado del octavo puesto
al 36 soen atractivo para las inversiones mineras.
Claro que, como muchos sabréis - os hablamos de
ello en nuestro boletin de Patreon - en octubre
de 2022 se produjo un cambio de color político
en este país. El nuevo primer ministro sueco,
el conservador Ulf Kristersson, ha sido
claro y cristalino con este tema. ¿Su
posición? Pues que quiere que Suecia se
convierta de nuevo en una nación minera.
Así que ahora este nuevo gobierno parece querer
facilitar que las empresas mineras se cojan el
pico y la pala y se pongan a trabajar a destajo.
Incluso quieren potenciar las inversiones de la
empresa pública de minería LKAB, que es la
mayor productora de hierro de toda Europa.
Claro que, ya que hablamos de Suecia,
el nuevo gobierno tiene otro as en la
manga que seguro no os va a dejar
indiferentes. Ni más ni menos,
quieren reforzar su papel y convertirse en
una especie de potencia nuclear [De uso civil]
[Madre mia, a Greta le debe estar
dando un parraque de tanto disgusto]
¡Atentos!
(LA SUECIA 3.0)
Suecia, uno de los países
ecologistas por antonomasia,
podría convertirse en una de las
grandes potencias nucleares europeas.
Hablamos de energía nuclear civil, claro está.
En Estocolmo todavía no se han planteado,
que nosotros sepamos, lo de las armas nucleares,
pero lo de la energía de los átomos como una de
las claves del futuro sí que está sobre la mesa.
Y parece que van en serio. De hecho,
la clave del nuevo gobierno sería la
de sustituir el concepto “100% energías
renovables” por el de “100% energías libres
de fósiles”. Lo que significa la entrada
en la ecuación de la producción nuclear.
Y la verdad es que si lo pensáis un
momento, tiene todo el sentido del mundo.
(La apuesta sueca pasará concretamente por
los SMR, los pequeños reactores modulares.
Para ello están dispuestos a modificar
la legislación actual y dar garantías de
crédito públicas que hasta ahora solo estaban
disponibles para las energías renovables.
Y no solo eso. Incluso quieren prohibir
por ley que un nuevo gobierno intente
agilizar la clausura de reactores
nucleares arbitrariamente. Es decir,
quieren blindar las inversiones
en este tipo de energía.
De hecho, todo esto se ha plasmado en un
acuerdo, el Acuerdo de Tidö. Un acuerdo
que permitió formar gobierno y que se alcanzó
entre los partidos del bloque de las derechas:
los demócratas cristianos, los liberales,
los moderados y los demócratas de Suecia.)
Tal cual como lo oís. Un acuerdo político
entre cuatro partidos que apuntala la energía
nuclear. Y no olvidéis que estamos hablando
de Suecia, ¡es todo un giro de 180 grados!
Y aún más Este acuerdo también contiene un
compromiso para desarrollar la legislación
que sea necesaria para implantar
pequeños reactores modulares en
el país. Reactores que se consideran
el futuro de la energía nuclear civil.
(Para ello se prevé acabar con el límite
que impone la Ley sueca de un máximo de
10 reactores nucleares operando al mismo tiempo,
se permitirá construir en nuevas localizaciones
diferentes a las de las actuales plantas
y se simplificará el proceso de permisos.
Para que os hagáis una idea de lo que
esto significa, si actualmente Suecia
cuenta con seis reactores que le proporcionan
alrededor del 31 por ciento de la energía,
el pedazo nuclear del mix energético del
futuro en Suecia podría ser cercano al 50%.)
Esto significa, ni más ni menos,
que la energía nuclear podría convertirse
en la energía base en el país escandinavo,
con las renovables, que no son regulares,
como apoyo para los picos de demanda.
Por el momento dos empresas ya tienen
firmado un memorándum para planear el
despliegue del futuro reactor modular japonés
BWRX-300 de la General Electric Hitachi,
algo que pondría a Suecia a la vanguardia
de las nuevas energías a nivel europeo.
("Los SMR pueden proporcionar tanto a la
industria como a los municipios electricidad,
calor e hidrógeno predecibles y libres de
combustibles fósiles. [...] Junto con la nueva
energía eólica, la nueva energía nuclear será una
pieza crucial del rompecabezas de la transición
climática". - Laurent Leveugle Jefe del estudio
de viabilidad de nueva construcción de Fortum)
Ya lo veis, los suecos quieren volver a
jugar. La gran pregunta -o mejor dicho
las dos grandes preguntas- son… ¿lo
conseguirán? ¿Les dejarán hacerlo?
Pues bien, por el momento lo único que sabemos
es que el estudio para construir pequeños
reactores modulares en Suecia se completará
a finales de 2023 o a principios de 2024.
Como siempre, estaremos muy atentos de
todo lo que pase en el país escandinavo,
pero mientras tanto las preguntas son para ti.
¿Logrará Suecia convertirse en el país clave para
la transición energética a nivel europeo gracias
a su industria minera? ¿Podrán llevar a cabo sus
ambiciosos planes nucleares en el largo plazo?
Déjanos tus respuestas aquí abajo,
en los comentarios. Y recuerda,
si te ha gustado este vídeo no olvides darle
like y suscribirte a nuestro canal para
no perderte ninguna de las novedades que vayan
llegando. También recuerda que puedes apoyarnos
activamente uniéndose a nuestra comunidad en
Patreon. Os dejamos el enlace en la descripción.
Una vez más, gracias por estar
ahí. Un saludo y hasta la próxima.